what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar
and today i will be addressing the new
major developments
in the black clover story including the
epic
asta and yami team action against dante
the reveal about the importance of
anti-magic
to this fight and osta's extremely
dangerous
deal with the devil the action is off
the charts
the stakes are as high as they've ever
been so let's
get into it if you enjoyed the
blacklover content on this channel and
you want to see more you know what to do
leave a like to let me know it really
does help and if you're new to anime pro
or you just haven't subscribed yet
please consider subscribing and hitting
that notification bell to turn
on all notifications you can also hit me
up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
finally this video will of course
contain black clover manga spoilers we
are dealing with the very latest
developments in the story
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned
at the end of the previous chapter we
witnessed
that incredible and heartwarming moment
when yami admitted that he cannot win
this battle against dante alone
and so he asked for asta's help
he actually called asta by name and told
him that they have to work together
to take on dante this one brief but
iconic moment
says a lot about the development of the
story in several aspects
first up this says that dante really is
incredibly strong
if yami an overpowered character with
extremely rare
and strong magic and an ability to
always surpass his limits
can't be dante without help then dante
really is
a terrifyingly strong opponent second
the fact that yami asked for asta's help
shows that he really does
trust asta asta has come a long way
since the time he first
joined the black bulls as a rookie who
was born without magic and who was like
the biggest
underdog at this point in the story yami
has clearly noticed
asta's amazing development both as a
mage
and as a person the latest chapter picks
up right after this iconic moment
as austin yami stand together and face
down the stubbornly strong dante
dante doesn't seem terribly worried
about the fact that he now has two
opponents in
fact dante's actually entertained by
this battle and he loves the challenge
of facing a strong opponent
like yami yami tells asta to follow his
lead
as the two black bulls charge at dante
at
the same time both asta and yami show
impressive speed and technique as they
use their swords to attack
dante but of course dante just keeps
regenerating every time yami cuts him
and
as he regenerates his body really does
become more and more deformed
in earlier chapters dante talked about
how he doesn't like
using this regeneration magic because it
deforms his body
and clearly he had a point dante's body
proportions are now completely out of
whack
and he looks more like a demonic monster
than a human
this really is a great battle and i had
to stop and appreciate
all these action-packed panels that
tabata has created for us
as a manga lover i'm always so impressed
to see black and white
still images on a page that are able to
convey so much
action and power in such a short period
of time
and as much as i do love manga i
definitely can't wait to see
this fight animated because it's going
to be glorious
back to the fight itself no matter how
much damage yami inflicts on dante
dante is able to regenerate but in spite
of this
yami is convinced that asta's anti-magic
is the key to ultimately defeating dante
while dante seems to be totally cool
with taking hits from yami
he seems to be a lot more cautious about
avoiding asta's
anti-magic attacks in fact i don't think
that asta managed to land a single
clean-cut anti-magic attack on dante
in this whole chapter when yami sees
this
it confirms his suspicion that
anti-magic
is the crucial ingredient to defeating
dante
while dante can easily recover from a
dark magic attack
it seems that anti-magic is a different
story
and so if asta can get the better of
dante and land some hits on him
perhaps dante really will be defeated
however
asta is disappointed in his performance
so far
even though he has made a ton of
progress during the course of the past
six months
and even though he is doing his best to
support yami asta feels that he is just
getting in the way
nothing he has done so far has been able
to affect dante in any meaningful way
osta just isn't strong enough or fast
enough at this point in time
to successfully defeat someone as
overpowered as dante
this is totally understandable when we
take into account asta's
age and how he spent most of his life
without any magic
but osta is still disappointed in
himself because of this
asta decides to turn to his own demon
the demon inside his grimoire asta
is suddenly able to talk to his demon
just as easily as dante was able to talk
to lucifer
several chapters ago to me this says
that asta
and his demon are starting to forge a
closer bond
they are becoming closer but only time
will tell whether that's a good thing or
a bad thing
at any rate asta tells the anti-magic
demon that he had felt his anger
earlier when they failed to defeat dante
in battle
asta doesn't know why this made the
demon so angry
but it is clear that osta's demon wants
to defeat dante just as much as
asta does for that reason asta
asks his demon to lend him his power his
true power the implication of course is
that so
far asta has been using only a small
fraction
of his demon's abilities and there is
still a lot more power that asta could
tap into
if the anti-magic demon allows it asta's
demon agrees to lend him the true power
of a devil
but he explains that this power is
beyond asta's current capabilities
put simply asta wouldn't be able to
handle that power on his own
as a result the demon proposes a deal in
return for giving asta
access to his true demon power the
anti-magic demon
says that he will need to take part of
osta's
body this is nothing short of a deal
with the devil
and the demon asks asta whether he is
sure that he really wants to do this
this definitely isn't something to take
lightly making a deal with the devil
is no joke and it could turn out to be
very costly for asta
in the long term as we know for hundreds
and even thousands of years of human
civilization
when anyone makes a deal with the devil
in some work of fiction
unwanted and unpredictable negative
consequences
are inevitable so asta has to really be
careful here those who make a deal with
the devil
almost always come to regret it at least
that is the common trope in most works
of fiction that feature some sort of
deal with the devil but asta says that
his dream
is to one day become the wizard king and
he can't possibly become the wizard king
if he cannot overcome this obstacle that
he is facing
right now asta was born without magic
so the power of his anti-magic demon is
the only magical ability that he will
ever be able to use
for that reason asta has to find a way
to access
more of his demon's power he has to
learn to handle the true
power of the anti-magic demon just
training really hard for six months
clearly wasn't
enough it definitely made asta a lot
stronger
but that in itself wasn't enough to
challenge someone of dante's caliber
in order to defeat someone like dante
asta will have
to go a step further he will have to
resort to more
drastic measures even if that means
making a deal with the devil
and beyond just his dream of becoming
the wizard king
asta also wants to live up to captain
yami's expectations
he wants to justify the faith that yami
had placed
in him when he invited asta to fight as
a team
so asta is determined to do what he has
to do to help yami finally defeat dante
and he is willing to accept the
consequences
the anti-magic demon agrees to give asta
more of his power
and the very last panel of the chapter
shows osta
awakening and manifesting the maximum
amount of power that he is able to
handle
at this time demonic darkness begins to
cover
much of asta's body and his entire right
arm
now appears to be completely consumed by
demonic
darkness the chapter ends with yami
smiling
as the newly powered up asta prepares to
challenge
dante i really liked this chapter
it had great action and teamwork between
our boys yami and asta
and it had some major reveals and
developments that will have important
consequences for the rest of the story
in this chapter it was seemingly
confirmed that asta's anti-magic
is the key to defeating dante this is
something that many of us
speculated about but now it seems that
dante is definitely worried
about anti-magic far more than dark
magic
the other major development is asta
making a deal
with his devil a deal that will allow
him to awaken
new levels of power but that will also
cost him
dearly from what we've seen so far it
looks like the anti-magic demon has
completely taken over
osta's arm so what will happen to that
arm now is this change permanent
or is it something that is going to last
only for the duration of this fight
and then go back to normal is this arm
and now
going to be controlled by the demon
himself
or will asta still have full control
over it as he always has
and in the case that this change really
is permanent
then could this be only the beginning of
a far
bigger and more sinister change in asta
definitely let me know what you guys
think will asta regret
making this deal with the devil is
asta's demon
actually scheming behind the scenes and
planning to take over asta's body
bit by bit body part by body part
is the anti-magic demon going to take
advantage of asta's commitment to get
stronger and become the wizard king
in order to slowly consume more of
asta's body
and maybe even his personality please
share your thoughts
on this crazy chapter down in the
comments below
and definitely let me know what you
think is going to happen next
if you enjoyed this blacklover video and
you want us to keep it going please
leave a like to let me know
it really does help and if you happen to
be new to anime outpour or you just
haven't subscribed yet
please consider subscribing and hitting
that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're gonna
miss a lot of our videos even if you're
subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
i wanna give a big thank you to all of
our anime upper patrons for making
videos like this one possible
special thanks to all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata
alolan adam the world steelers acquired
respect
pate heffa jonathan king brandon aviles
papa smurf
the school bus king riser emperor otaku
ricardo martinez
thomas jones kin mano michael hyde
and jaden the vector and i can't forget
all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan jason wilson
kings eldris anatoly kazatsky on hell
cruz
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci alicia
octa jessica kayla fond
hinokami and water bonnie parks zodiac
12 rathune de ora kraken arles
and deadly saint if you enjoy our videos
and you feel that they provide value to
you please consider supporting us on
patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
so
[Music]
you